[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans la saison 2 de
l'émission allons-nous l'émission Ça ne
savent découvert un ensemble vous allez
parler alors allons-nous
[Musique]
dans la commune de Saint-Denis plus
précisément sur la
D41 alors si nous garde bien ici on a le
petit panneau ici la montagne et là nous
voyons que c'est le
le panneau est indiqué qu'à nous
plusieurs
points et note l'endroit à nous au sano
va laisser l'ile LED à Guillaume sera
l'occasion aussi pour nous de découvrir
que ça allait son histoire allez
allons-nous
alors là nous sommes des bois on arrive
au lieu de la fenêtre mais avant sinon
garde pas là pas là ça va Colorado nous
nous ça va pas Colorado nous que ça
l'écrit Siphano
a
770 m d'altitude une destination c'est
l'île est à Guillaume il est à Guillaume
il est bien par là mais avant ça
nouvelle
ça arrive à côté d'un point de vue
ôter les gardiens ils voté alors ok ça
nous fait mal ici
bien connu ça et snugga là
là c'est la ville de Saint-Denis en tout
cas on en est magnifique temps papa nous
va continuer notre petite balade jusqu'à
l'illette à Guillaume allez allons-nous
quand vous été coincé en France rien que
ça même moins dépendants
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur bonjour comment
allez-vous très bien et vous ça va bien
ça va alors dites-moi qu'est-ce que vous
êtes en train de faire là je suis en
train de descendre à l'Ilette à
Guillaume d'accord depuis le Colorado ok
la petite balade du vendredi quoi et la
randonnée que vous avez fait là est-ce
que c'est un sentier qui est assez
facile pour tous les rangs qui ont envie
de venir alors c'est facile il y a
quelques passages délicat avec des
éboulis à traverser donc prudent
notamment en période de fortes pluies
bien se renseigner savoir si le sentier
est ouvert il peut être fermé
quelquefois après voilà comme tous les
sentiers ça montre ça descend faut être
en condition physique en bonne condition
physique mais c'est pas non plus un
sentier trop trop compliqué trop extrême
puis c'est un site qui est pas forcément
très très connu et qui mérite le détour
et le passage quoi en tout cas c'est
bien dit merci
comment il est la réunion s'amène parle
pas nous aller nous verrez la même un
peu de respect pour
vraiment après depuis son lit bout de la
terre dans le paradis pour comprendre
faut un démon de mon pays la réunion
nous les la même mais mon pays comment
il est
est et ben voilà alors me regarde ma
montre au bout de 2h30 demain arrive sur
le site de l'Ilette à Guillaume et tombe
bien en train de faire des photos
bonjour madame bonjour vous voulez bien
les biens et où oui ça va très bien
on est en visite aujourd'hui sur le site
et je prends des photos des travaux de
consolidation qui ont été réalisés ces
derniers mois alors mettez-moi un petit
peu bête
à Guillaume c'est une ancienne colonie
pénitentiaire pour enfants
cette colonie a été construite en 1864
est dirigé par la Congrégation des
spiritants et qui avec l'accord du
gouvernement en colonial de l'époque
avait pour mission de le redressement
moral par l'éducation religieuse et le
travail des mineurs délinquants d'accord
et ce que nous connaissons un peu comme
alors ce sont les enfants qui ont
construit la colonie tous les soucis je
des anciens bâtiments il y en a une
douzaine en tout sur le site ont été
construits par les enfants même la route
à l'époque qui
amené vers les lettres a été construite
par les enfants est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'important de justement de montrer ce
patrimoine là oui ça fait partie de
l'histoire de la Réunion et puis même
pour la mémoire de ses enfants qui ont
été placés ici et qui pour certains sont
décédés ici donc c'est important de
refaire revivre cette cette histoire et
de leur rendre hommage on va mettre en
place avec notamment la Direction du
Tourisme et des espaces naturels du
département une signalétique pour rendre
compte de cette histoire aux personnes
qui viendrai visiter le lieu si vous
voulez avoir plus d'informations sur les
travaux vous pouvez aller voir mon
collègue Thierry caillasson
c'est bien ouais ça va bien alors
Thierry James
de maçonnerie spécialisée en pièce sèche
et des menuiseries des menuisiers qui
ont fait des travaux de reconstitution
des murs et des témoins des murs pour
préserver les murs qui restait quand on
dit reconstitution que ça veut dire là
par exemple
ok les maçons ont pu refaire ce mur là à
l'identique en retrouvant les pierres
qu'il fallait poser en puzzle là on est
dans un bassin ok de l'eau arrivée par
là et ça c'était plein parce que le sol
est étanche il pense qu'on tienne du
coup vous aura beaucoup de partenaires
autour de ça aussi les travaux ont coûté
autour de 700 000 750 000 euros au
départ allemand payant en partie mais
c'est des travaux qui ont été
subventionnés patrimoine l'attaque fait
ADR en tout cas elle est vraiment
intéressante même ça a continué visite
au site là merci à vous merci
et ben voilà notre balade il est à
Guillaume la fille nous l'a vu c'était
pour une histoire quand même assez
sombre ok la Réunion on a gagné
et tout ça on vous a un prochain épisode
de l'émission à nous derrière la semaine
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]